mounir strasbourg si si j'y étais il est
deux heures du matin je rentre chez moi
il fait nuit noire
je marche seul et là il ya un gars qui
se met à me suivre
ouais ça dit d'aller boire un verre non
non c'est bon allez inverse qua non
c'est bon un verre alors déjà
complètement sourd tu dis non il entend
bien oui fait très plaisir est
impossible de s'en défaire une tâche de
myrtille plus d ça et puis s'incruste il
ya un moment j'ai eu peur il s'est
rapproché de moi il a fait que c'est
quoi ton problème pour aller boire
envers toi là je me suis dit ouh la
carène il est deux heures du matin il ya
personne autour de toi il a des bras
comme tes cuisses casse le code
je les regardais j'ai fait étape à
l'etna des baby loup le pen lui nous les
parties
c'est une technique implacable cadeau
vous voyez les pigeons printemps comme
ils sont sur la femelle il lâche rien
sellal et tranquille elle a rien demandé
à personne
eh ben c'est pareil n'y vont pas plus
loin que le cerveau d'un pigeon une
question mesdames à main levée combien
d'entre vous ont déjà été soulevée par
un relou dans la rue parce que vous êtes
une femme a devant derrière à bah ouais
l'unanimité il ya juste quelqu'un qui
était sur son portable etc à faire moi
messieurs à main levée combien d'entre
vous ont déjà été soulevée par un rôle
dans la rue parce que vous êtes un homme
là j'observe assez ça il y en a dans
l'oeuf au café-bar mois notre or j'avais
une perruque rousse et vos filets
ni homme ni femme vont être embêtés par
ce genre de personnes là en fait ces
gars là dans leur tête ils ont un mur et
quand tu dis non pim sa rom ou dit non
vim
le nom rebondi à c'est un vieux mur et
il a été construit à dix mille ans et le
ciment c'était l'homme décide la femme
soutient voilà du boudin et encore
maintenant quelqu'un qui soutient c'est
quelqu'un qui dit oui une femme ça
soutient donc ça dit oui bima le nom
rebondi il ya des femmes aussi qu'ils
ont ce mur le nombre d'entre elles avec
qui je discute qui me disent qu'elle
ramène chez elle une histoire d'un soir
et quand ça devient un intime sexuelle
elle le sent plus elles le veulent plus
il ya le fou quand même
elle pense non elles veulent non et
elles font hui bim le nom rebondi en
fait ce mur on l'a tous et toutes
c'est celui de la société dans lequel on
évolue et se mure il nous enferme et
nous ordonnent aux façon d'être
c'est la société elle prend les hommes
et à les enferme et muscle toi ya le
prends les femmes et elles les enferme
et rentrent pas on va couper du gras
voilà les rentrées et là nous ordonnent
aux attitudes une femme se doit d'être
mince dell sensible il ya du vent non
douce
tellement qu'à transpire du sucre
fait chaud en temps mais c'est du sucre
à l'ecoute où est ce que je vais bien
pouvoir trouver un homme à soutenir
anjou est une forêt la malène les hommes
c'est fort courageux ténébreux musclé
regarde moi cette instance theron de bus
car je vais diriger une entreprise mais
avant je vais tuer ce monstre écrit j'ai
peut-être une petite pipe et mais c'est
pas la taille qui compte
et toi le monstre est prévenu ou est-ce
que je peux trouver une femme pour me
soutenir
au choix est une forêt ces clichés 1
et pourtant dès qu'on sort de ses murs
on est jugée parce que les briques sont
malines dès que quelqu'un se faufiler
s'évade
elle condamne en passant par nous un
homme qui est doux sensible à l'ecoute
aulas la mauviette
puis hier il a pleuré c'est pas à cause
du fouta et puis il sent bon il doit
être d une femme qui dirige une
entreprise qui est courageuse organisée
et rigoureuse mais dirige comme un à
quel point est de mauvais poil
elle doit avoir ses règles on le dit ça
c'est devenu ordinaire le sexisme
ordinaire
on sait pas quand on a commencé on sait
pas s'arrêter de chocolat du coup
comment on fait pour le détecter et ben
moi un jour j'ai dû arrêter le sucre et
je me suis rendu compte que dans la
pizza il ya du sucre dans le pain dans
le souci son il y en a eh bien le
sexisme ordinaire c'est comme le sucre
c'est quand tu t'arrêtes que tu te rends
compte y en a partout
alors comment on fait on va pas dire les
ingrédients de ce qu'on vient de dire
autant pour moi ta pâte et règles eh ben
tu remplaces le féminin par le masculin
ou linverse et si ça sonne faux
sexy il ya du sucre dedans sexisme
ordinaire par exemple
tous les hommes avec un grand h ça veut
dire toutes les femmes ordinaires
toutes les femmes avec un grand f ça
veut dire tous les hommes sucre dans une
salle ya mille femmes et un homme ont
dit il le masculin l'emportent ordinaire
dans une salle il ya mille hommes et une
femme ont dit elle le femina m'emporte
sucre une nouvelle stagiaire qui vient
d'arriver
ça va ma petite un nouveau stagiaire
ça va mon petit sucre ça va ma belle ça
va mon beau sucre un manager à une
manager ça va ma chérie une manager un
manager ça va mon chéri elle te va bien
ta jupe
il va bien ton pantalon ça sous-entend
quand même con matin sucre un homme ça
pleure pas une femme ça pleure pas sucre
paix un homme ces résistants aux heures
supplémentaires et ça pas besoin de
s'occuper de ses enfants puis une femme
c'est résistantes aux heures
supplémentaires et saab a besoin de
s'occuper de ses enfants sucre sucre
sucre
si à chaque sexisme ordinaire on prenait
1 kg on serait soit tous obèses soit
avant l'été on arrêterait de parler pour
rentrer dans le maillot de bain être un
homme et une femme offre exactement les
mêmes compétences
sauf que depuis qu'on est comme ça on te
dit l' inverse
on fait ce qu'on nous apprend et on
devient ce qu'on nous a appris alors
qu'il faut qu'on devienne qui on est il
est grand temps mais damas messieurs de
mener la vie dure à ses murs qui nous
pourrissent la nôtre
ou alors c'est du vieux murs on est
d'accord un jeu rien qui pue le crépi
qui s'effrite mais encore maintenant
parfois il reste bien coincé entre les
dents ça moi je me le suis bien pris
parce que je suis femme et lesbiennes on
rajoute des briques tout dans la
longueur ça quand tu es lesbienne et que
tu le dis il ya des gens ils se font ils
s'imaginent des trucs sur ta vie privée
et intime mais de deux malades
fais toi ton film gagne-t-on césar et
arrêtent un
c'est quand je dis que je suis lesbienne
je suis pas en train de dire du nu du nu
du nu avant la clope après la cloche
j'ai dû arrêter de fumer
non je dis j'aime les femmes mais
amoureusement tu sors des cases et tu
dit non aux hommes
quand ce nom là il rebondit pour
certains hommes dire je suis lesbienne
ça veut dire un jeu couche qu'avec des
hommes surtout les livreurs de pizzas
popopopop et ma copine aussi que les
mecs lesbiennes et quand tu dis que tu
es lesbienne à quelqu'un pour la
première fois qu elle le réalise
tu es confronté à ce que j'appelle les
fissures iccat vous voyez ce que c'est
que suri 4 est bien la première fois que
tu dit une phrase banale comme la
semaine dernière avec ma chérie on était
au cinéma en face prise de conscience
que tu sors des murs et là tu as deux
possibilités la première à trausse
pétition ok elle sort des murs mais
finalement bon ça fera plus de monde au
prochain barbecue plus de murs 2 6m
introspection et la personne elle voit
que tu sors des murs façon des murs
propre autour des murs sont des murs les
différents sens du mot petit rire
nerveux on regarde à gauche à droite on
cherche de l'aide avant de vite vu
quelqu'un deuxième rire nerveux petit
pas chasser et là elle s'éloigne et elle
va parler toi elle va de juger et elle
va transformer tu vas devenir difforme
une grosse bouche un gros nez une
allergie aux arachides
mettez bien différent entre elles si
elles sont sûres ne pas te ressembler et
ça les rassure les emmurés et quand dans
la rue tu tiens la main ta chérie tu
attires les emmurés ils sortent de
partout aux deux lesbiennes et cela qui
fait le mec on peut filmer le walking
dead des emmurés je les appelle les ouga
ouga rien à voir que le marsupilami les
aux gars c'est un petit pourcentage des
sommes qu'on pas fini leur évolution de
darwin 1 ils en sont au début ils sont
bien dans les genoux comme ça peuvent
partir au ski ça rebondit important des
trous dans les jeans pour gagner en
souplesse et la bouche toujours ouverte
pour respirer
sinon j'oublie
et quand deux femmes se tiennent la main
la main de van gogh à eybens il reste
fidèle à lui même et d'un coup il veut
savoir et vient communiqué où il fit e
vous êtes lesbiennes non c'est ma soeur
on va à la messe oh je me disais aussi
vous pouvez pas être lesbienne vous êtes
belle eau et toutes les 10 minutes ton à
un autre tu les attire tient dimanche où
le fut vous cherchez un truc à 3,1 non
je cherche un restaurant
il connaît depuis deux centièmes de
seconde il te demande si tu cherches un
truc à 3 il s'allume en néon rouge le
dur
vous êtes by enfin bi multiprise et
quand tu lui renvoie dans ses murs à sa
propre ignorance et toi tu dois gagner
un pari où tu es bête dissonance
cognitive
ça résonne entre les murs ou le ping
pong des emmurés tous et moi il est hors
de question que je lâche la main de ma
she rien que ce quelqu'un du coup ben
quand tu as pu mur tu es libre mais tu
deviens visible et du coup ben tu es
différent est différente
et quand on est différent parfois on se
sent seul alors que quand on est
différent on est exceptionnel et
aujourd'hui là vous êtes tous
exceptionnels et toutes exceptionnelles
et vous savez pourquoi
mais parce qu'on est tous différents il
n'y a pas un adn sur terre qui ressemble
à un autre
le tout c'est de se le rappeler en
partageons moi j'ai une philosophie de
vie
alors je vais en profiter pour la
partager avec vous parce que l'ambiance
est très bonne ici un philosophie de vie
c'est où que je sois il ya quelqu'un
avec qui je vais pouvoir discuter
que ce soit dans un restaurant dans une
file d'attende dans un avion il ya une
personne avec qui je vais pouvoir
discuter et je vais lui enlever une
brique et elle va m'enlever une brique
et puis je vais partager mes expériences
de vie et écouter celle des autres pully
briques s'effrite
la plus grande faiblesse de ses murs et
d'être comme le père noël il existe
parce qu'on y croit et plus on partage
mois on y croit et plus les murs
s'effondrent à et plus on est nombreux à
le faire plus au niveau tractopelle
alors après il ya un cocktail là bas ça
vous dit qu'on fasse des travaux
[Applaudissements]